[Music]
the emoji movie is one of the most
famously despised films in recent years
with a premise that's beyond desperate
and gimmicky a trailer with far more
dislikes than likes and the Rotten
Tomatoes score of 8 friggin percent this
movies hate levels have reached
legendary status now usually I like
whatever I review to have some sort of
nostalgic time but with all the requests
I've been getting to review this I can't
see the film not becoming a nostalgic
landmark of hey business there's a lot
to get to so let's get right to it
insert your emoji icon brutally stabbing
the emoji movie here does that emoji not
exist yet it will let's take a look at
currently one of the most hated films
ever the emoji movie it starts off with
the Columbia logo having its picture
taken and given an emoji
I immediately hate all life we're told
how everybody is always on their phones
but seeing how this is a Sony movie with
Sony products they don't portray this as
a bad thing that's our user now it's you
can call him Riley it's not his name but
it's who he is
tensions fans get shorter and shorter
and you're probably not even listening
to me right now who has the time to type
out actual words I mean the writers
clearly didn't type out actual words I
just assumed the entire script with Ness
we see the emojis are alive and lived in
a place called Tex tapas it's just a
hint of how hard they're trying in this
movie where we see our main character is
named met voiced by TJ Miller Matt it
turns out is super happy but his job /
personality assignment for life requires
him to be unimpressed by anything we
have business to attend to
what kind of business monkey business
I'll admit I got chuckle out of the
emoticons being old and elderly but
don't worry there's a whole bad movie of
jokes to make up for it is that the time
hey my eyes are up here pal oh sorry I
was looking at your boobs clock
I don't even follow that so it goes to
talk to his father played by dammit
Steve a right why haven't you fired your
agent yet no really that's how he's
billed now I'm not letting you go to
work today
what you're just not ready son his dad
said mess and ready to go on the phone
and be a man face and in keeping with
the film's theme the moment is
immediately followed by crap should we
wash our hands that's Patrick Stewart
playing shit and his character's name is
poop just doing my duty
oh sweet Jesus Matt insists he's ready
fell and he visits the original emoji
smiler played by Damon Maya Rudolph why
haven't you also fired your agent by the
way if you're wondering no that's not
how she builds herself now but it is a
picture of this character hanging
herself she says you just wait for the
user to pick you and then you get
scanned into his conversation and that
skin will get sent right up to Alex's to
tax Punk
yes naughty scan me twice last night it
was wonderful I kind of replied to
Edie's text what should I write nothing
nothing words aren't cool that's like a
film mocking a generations idiocy while
also adding to that generations idiocy
Matt gets chosen though and panics
giving a different face
what is that emoji just look around you
it's called the audience's got to him
reaction seeing how apparently this has
never happened in history I guess
everything goes wrong and the scanner is
destroyed in fact for a system and a
civilization that doesn't need to exist
they really should have more safety
precautions effective phones have souls
living in them does that mean that the
machines they use also have souls living
in them do the gears inside that toaster
also have little toasters inside the
town called toe stop Alice is anyone who
made this realizing how stupid this all
was yet so they think mez a malfunction
which yeah honestly sounds right as he
talks to his friend poop and we discover
a whole new emotional realm that really
evolves his character yeah just kidding
to make sure jokes
we all have accidents you're so soft
poop not too soft I hope I did this role
for my grandkids who are not getting
Christmas presents this year
smiler says the only thing to do is to
delete them forcing antivirus BOTS to
wipe them out I know a lot of people
compare this to inside out but it
doesn't help that smiler is literally
joy except with different hair and
complete lack of joy to quote John
Lovitz from rat race you should sue
somebody man escapes though and comes
across another unpopular emoji called
high-five play by James Corden who
thinks he's being hunted too they'll
never find us down here welcome to the
loser lounge where the emojis you never
get used hangouts I guess that can be
funny but you're missing the really
unpopular ones like pregnant wife
drinking emoji Ghostbusters reboot emoji
and breadstick emojis dick sauce needs
bread stick emojis
just find the hacker and get
reprogrammed high-five tells them to
find a hacker in the piracy app to get
reprogram so that everything will go
back to normal but all I need is the
hacker
today's your lucky day let's roll the
high-five also realizes he can do that
to become popular again kind of weird he
didn't originally think of that for
himself but they had to write this fast
to start another Sony Cinematic Universe
give him some credit there was little
toilet paper to write this on
they walk outside a text appleís and
enter the wallpaper in the phone again
could be a clever idea but it just feels
like more commercials for products and
apps on Sony phones we chats candy droid
it's especially tragic because that's a
real good commentary on social media in
this conversation how does he know so
many people none of these people know
him but they like him yet rather just
have a real friend a real friend how's
that gonna get you anywhere what you
need are fans but again it's kind of
lost when you're in the film called the
emoji movie it's like slipping in
fascism is bad and triumph of the will
something's gonna get lost they make it
to the piracy app which is disguised as
a dictionary app using a different skin
what could a teenage boy possibly want
to hide from his parents
what's this film rated again could have
been worst job roaming through the
drunken VeggieTales they come across a
hacker named jailbreak played by dama
Anna Faris why haven't you oh god damn
forget it and yes that is how she's
built Fanta fire spots come in though
and jailbreak agrees to help Matt after
she sees he can make many different
emoji faces they land in candy crush
because shit
we're not enough like other Disney
animated films are we the game obviously
thinks you're a candy what do we do very
still it's more likely the users mom
downloaded it so it probably won't be
played for a while after a mere 20
minute absence we finally see not Riley
again as he tries to hit on the girl he
likes but candy crunch keeps making
sounds so he calls customer service to
get the phone fixed I'd like to make an
appointment
this phone is playing games with me and
yeah that's all the insight we need on
him for a while it's amazing how much I
know about this kid compared to inside
out like the boy they finally get him
out of candy crush and they realize they
have to get to the cloud to reprogram
him after this strong feminist statement
you know women are always coming up with
stuff that men are taking credit for you
know what disgust
and as parents go looking for him while
also being followed by the bots so they
distract them in the YouTube app what do
you do No
yeah be an average hour ok these jokes
are over five years old place your bets
cat video or why even make another guess
you know that's it hey what's this
YouTube kids video with Elsa the Joker
and spider-man oh that's gonna change
the film's rating
[Applause]
[Music]
the bot spot our heroes trying to get to
the cloud through Dropbox by going
through the Just Dance app not entirely
sure how that path works on my phone
either as it looks like they have to
dance or death what does she mean by out
digital death Just Dance got a lot
darker in recent years but jailbreak
can't dance Oh Matt shows her how oh
[Music]
well he knows how to dance
clearly this is a relationship material
why does a hand have a butt why is that
my biggest question but more importantly
why does a hand have a butt I do never
call this Q&A portion of the game the
emoji table
I'd rather do the Macarena with the
Mario than the emoji pop while on fire
but jailbreak reveals she's really a
princess emoji the one said to have
gotten off the phone although she
clearly didn't you're the princess emoji
you never got off the phone now we don't
know that maybe she's just one of the
minions playing dress-up everything else
from this movie is stolen well it's been
about 12 minutes yes we can check in on
not Reilly again God he plays such a big
part he deletes the dance app because
it's making noise resulting in hi-5
getting trashed Mae wants to go save him
leaving too yeah I'm just gonna leave
him to get deleted you gotta look out
for number one
well what good is it to be number one if
there are any other numbers don't try to
be an actual movie now that both sailed
with a monkey business joke so they go
through Spotify where they sail along
the sound waves and jailbreak discusses
why she wants to get to the cloud did
you realize it on the first emoji said a
woman can either be a princess or a
bride that's why I need to get to the
cloud where you can be whoever you want
to be okay first it looks like there's a
lot of female emojis there so clearly
that's changed second didn't they say
that smiler was the original emoji does
she not count in those two choices third
princess is really not a personality
this is very different from this but
whatever maybe she just doesn't like the
idea of emojis whatever the reason is
she wants to go to the cloud so they go
into the trash to save high-five leaving
all the other trash characters to die a
slow and horrible death normally I'd be
upset that with a movie but honestly I'm
more frustrated with how many characters
don't die in a particularly odd scene
and that's saying a lot for this film
his parents look through not Riley's
pictures with his folks and have I guess
a tender moment I say I guess because I
honestly had no idea this is supposed to
be heartwarming or funny right now I'm
so overwhelmed with passionate feelings
for you
[Music]
burns with the intensity of a red-hot
flame we'll always have Paris marrying
so they make it to the drop box and ride
their way to the fire wall they try
different passwords they think not Riley
would have using mez different
expressions but they all fail we've
tried all the important things in Alex's
life his favorite pet sport is a
favorite grandma if only this movie gave
him a personality like finding out that
he has a favorite grandma that's the
most I know about him but high five saw
an email in the trash to a girl he liked
but never talks to and I guess it turns
out that's the password
I guess that's romantic you having the
password be a person you never talk to
if you're a stalker hey it's a creepy
ass clock already they make it to the
cloud though it Mendez he wants to stay
with jailbreak she turns him down though
because movies I like you just the way
you are but I had a plan
I'm not just some princess gene waiting
for my prince doll that old excuse if I
have a plan and we suck at writing
emotional conflict timeless tale man
leaves but gets captured by one of the
bots and jailbreak decides to go back
and save him let's go get him here I
suddenly want to record all caps and
hate everything Nez brought back to be
deleted but his parents come in to speak
up for him I am the same malfunction
gene does
and it doesn't affect my voice because
you know I got a stick jailbreaking
high-five crashing but it looks like
it's too late as the user is deleting
the phone to fix it
however the girl he likes is there and
it looks like how do I even explain this
they can always send an emoji to her and
since mez the only one that can do a
bunch of different emojis its decided he
should go because you know sometimes a
Sony phone and an emoji can get you the
love of your life yep that's what we're
doing that's that's one supercool emoji
a lot of feelings in one I get it I like
that you're one of those guys who can
actually express his feelings you know
through the most unemotional laziest way
possible he pushed a button do that he
stops the phone from being deleted
because she found love and all of
techstop Alyssa's putback high-five is
so emotional he doesn't even match his
voice to his lip movements so there was
really a jackass who said we should ADR
him more dialogue they have a big dance
party because I think it's law now every
anime film should end with one and the
emojis are used once again to replace
all human emotion a fair analysis for
this goddamn movie as a whole
[Music]
and that is one of the most hated films
to come out of recent years and believe
it or not I might have an unpopular
opinion all I still hate it but I think
it's just run-of-the-mill back I've seen
much much much much much worse in all my
years reviewing this film does have a
touch of creativity at least two
inventive lines and enough of a visual
eye to be colorful and somewhat
imaginative I've seen films that have
none of those qualities but I'd be lying
if I said I didn't understand why it has
pissed people off so much the corporate
advertising is not at all hidden which
wouldn't be too bad if they could
utilize it in a clever way like the lego
movie did work it into the storytelling
like why couldn't we find out more about
the kid through the phone maybe looking
through his history of pictures and text
we could see his flaws and maybe the
flaws tie into the problems the emojis
are going through but if we did that we
wouldn't have our bullshit resolution
we're a Sony product saves the day it is
bad and it's important to remember why
it's bad so other films trying to do
commercial tie-ins because let's be
honest there's gonna be plenty of those
in the future can at least work it into
their story better so yeah I can't even
say it's one of the worst films I've
ever seen take that for what it's worth
I guess as an advertising tie-in it is
uniquely bad but as a bad movie among a
sea of bad movies all I can give it is
an honest and simple man five minutes
tops our critic and I deserve to be
challenged by a more creatively bad
movie scooby-dooby-doo there's a third
one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
words are cool
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing
children incorporated this is an
international nonprofit organization
that helps provide support to children
primarily through child sponsorship and
partnering with nearly 300 projects in
23 countries around the world they
believe that all children deserve access
to basic needs and an education so that
they may be healthy and have the
opportunity to become contributing
members of their communities thanks to
past and current supporters around the
globe they serve over 20,000 children
annually to date over 300,000 children
have been provided opportunities for
growth and education and have
experienced the support and
encouragement their program provides if
you look at their site in their YouTube
channel you can see all the various ways
they help and encourage children to be
everything they can possibly be
there's so much love and dedication
that's spread throughout this
organization and you can play a big part
in that click on the link and see how
you can help a child achieve his or her
full potential
[Music]
you